who's who's dividing and what's the
benefit to them to divide
so many things i think you're just
seeing a perfect you know there's like a
perfect storm
uh i don't think you can say oh there's
like one cause
you know like oh you know i'm not gonna
say oh it's you know donald trump or oh
it's nancy pelosi or you know no it's a
perfect storm you know our media you
know i think listen the way our media
works right now
um you know where people are
incentivized to
be extreme that's how you get attention
attention gets you followers followers
get your money it gets you voters
you know i think that that certainly
plays into the divisiveness
if we look at how our elections are run
right now you know with you know with
our primary system that kind of
incentivizes people who are out on the
fringes
as well uh i think i think that is
that's a challenge the amount of money
that's in politics has been
been a challenge demographic changed the
united states you know we're facing huge
demographic changes
that we have to figure out how to
navigate through that you know all these
things are happening
and you know they've happened before i
mean the united states has had to like
figure out how to be the united states
and constantly reinvent itself
um before but we're in one of those
moments right now and if we don't figure
it out like it's
you know it's it's not just a given that
we figure it out
how do you figure it out though i mean
you have to realize we have a lot of
smart people in this country right we
have
we have a lot of people when you when
you read the book there's a book
barbarians to bureaucrats the author
lawrence miller talks about the fact
that every society organization company
goes through certain faces first you got
the prophet which is the founding
fathers like hey
here's an idea of america we're going to
go away from britain and this is what
we're going to do
then you got the barbarians these are
guys that are willing to go to war and
fight and do the dirty work they get the
scars
you know all this dirty things that
happens to them but they handle it
they're not afraid then you have the
builders and explorers which is the
industrial age
we build trade mobile trains you know
hotels buildings all this stuff
then shows up the administrators the
lawmakers
then the bureaucrats then the
aristocrats and they screw the whole
thing up
we're in the bureaucrat in this
aristocrat phase right now
but it says in order to save it and
prevent this from happening
you need a synergist or a group of
synergists
who is a synergist today and and does
this climate give birth to a synergist
who would you call a synergist today i
mean because when you're saying we got
to figure out a way to bring it together
we are hearing that but who can do that
today is it even
possible to do that today
i don't know i don't i mean i don't i
don't have i don't have an answer i
i agree you know i think there's a lot
of credence to the to the template that
you just laid out
uh laid out there uh and i think
you know the contribution i'm just
trying to make is to
is to call greater attention to those
types of arguments like that this is the
challenge of today like it's you know if
if someone's telling you that this this
one political figure is the reason why
in this individual is the reason why
we're having all these problems
uh i would say you know you're not
seeing the forest past the trees
i mean you know this there are bigger
things afoot so
i think the first step is just for
having your your thinking straight on
where we're at in this
in this longer cycle um but i don't have
one
single prescriptive thing we can do to
cure all of our societal ills at this
moment
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye